uh so while some people are looking to
head out of town thousands of course are
going to be coming here to las vegas for
the unofficial start of summer
all enhanced by the removal of a lot of
coronavirus restrictions here in the
valley
hector mejia live this afternoon with a
look ahead to what could be a very busy
holiday weekend hector
now well a lot of pent up demand means a
surge and travel and we're at mccarran
international airport where we've been
seeing
waves of crowds on and off throughout
the day this is actually a small crowd
right now
and according to triple a this is the
second hottest destination
in the entire country and also 37
million people are expected to vacation
for memorial day weekend
that's 60 percent more travelers in 2020
when only 23 million people went out at
the start of the pandemic
aaa also says las vegas is the number
one hotel booking spot in the west
so we can expect big crowds on the strip
this weekend and a lot of business
happening
and a lot of people say they are feeling
less stressed traveling this time around
when i got to the airport this morning i
was in
checked in through security in 20
minutes i said i'm becoming an expert at
this like i don't want to pack i know
what to wear
i usually come to vegas once a year and
i missed my trip last year to play golf
and
i was kind of depressed you know and
it's so much better being out here this
year
most are getting around by car though
and here's why not to hit the road this
weekend
the biggest traffic jams are expected
between three and six tonight
and if you are heading out it might be a
good idea to look up what the latest
coveted rules are
wherever it is you're going and back to
airports they are seeing nearly six
times
more people this year compared to last
year and that's for airports all across
the country
and remember masks are still mandatory
inside the airport and on a plane
if you are going to a airport this
weekend
reporting from mccarran hector mejia 8
news now back to you